praise God here's somebody right here
with a little fella in the background
what that could be what time is that
Bryan Callen in the background there
[Laughter]
what's up Brendon what's up do we got a
king under sting in for you getting your
ass waxed oh the kids you gotta do the
ring though you got to do the a-hole if
you're gonna do it yeah you know it's
the number one thing for guys when they
get wax what they call it balls balls
and butt
really yep Wow I wouldn't mind a little
bit of it but I had my girl wax inside
of my five because I wonder watch this
[ __ ] let me see how bad it hurts she
just wax inside my thigh bro it was the
worst pain I've ever been in I don't get
how girls do it what a little [ __ ] dog
dog I'll even gained five more meet me
at 245 deeper can handle the cut son
that's all I'm saying you need to whack
that duck tail hanging off your back bro
oh [ __ ] no you guys have any style in
here okay chin has some style that looks
great but the rest you [ __ ] boys
don't have [ __ ] okay you don't have to
wet oh I'm talking about do I still lack
you still wax yeah happy y'all ain't
[ __ ] are you still on that shitty hair
bra see both you and him have the same
[ __ ] haircut you and Brendan and
little dark Brendon oh I'm sorry the
store is all out of the John Daly wig my
bad bro this ain't a wig you freak this
is real hair prove it so here comes a
guy with a DC oh wait wait I say look
man yeah I've got my butt my butt wax
man you got to do it sometimes bro
especially if you used to use steroids
and stuff in high school no messy like
Jumanji [ __ ] we very thick I would
get it right now really yeah
go to the place and get it done Persian
lady we'll do it yeah oh that's a rough
they do what they beat they'll [ __ ]
call you their husbands name while they
do it to their angry
yeah you've done it before yeah she got
all fours oh you know you put your like
this yeah I look right in the eyes well
she doesn't I say take it yeah [ __ ] take
it daddy
take it female daddy I said I say cuz
I'm a [ __ ] man one day take it mom
like it's your belt look scared over
there oh really huh yeah if you quit
listening to matchbox 20 and get in the
game all y'all man y'all break from the
lighthouse soundtrack bro bro if you
turn down the base on that Kenny G a
little and pretty can have a life
experience talk baby alright Brooks and
Dunn live to get on all fours and call
someone mama where they rip the hair out
your [ __ ] bro
yeah dude if you back off the 24-hour
live feed from the Volcom festival
looking for deals on the hot topic
online you might live a little [ __ ]
double take it from Brendan who's
dressed like a bouncer at crystally as
closet in the gym Chris only man
[Music]
King nothing
[Music]